read acts 231 12-23 and when it was day
certain of the Jews banded together and
bound themselves under a curse saying
that they would neither eat nor drink
till they had killed Paul and they were
more than 40 which had made this Con uh
conspiracy and they came to the chief
priests and elders and said we have
bound ourselves under a great curse that
we will eat nothing until we have slain
Paul now therefore ye with the Council
signify to the chief captain that he
bring him down unto you tomorrow as
though ye would inquire something more
perfectly concerning him and we orever
he come near are ready to kill him and
when Paul's sister uh Paul's sister's
son his neph so Paul's sister's son his
nephew what did he do uh heard of their
lying in weight he went and entered into
the castle and told Paul then Paul
called one of the centurions unto him
and said bring this young man unto the
chief Captain for he hath a certain
thing to tell him so he took him and
brought him to the chief captain and
said Paul The Prisoner called me unto
him and prayed me to bring this young
man unto thee who hath something to say
unto thee then the chief Captain took
him by the hand and went with him aside
privately and asked him what is that
thou Hast to tell
me and he said the Jews have agreed to
desire thee that thou wouldest bring
down Paul tomorrow into the council as
though they would inquire something or
somewhat sorry somewhat of him more
perfectly but do not thou yield unto
them for they lie in waight for him of
them more than 40 men which have bound
themselves with an oath that they will
neither eat nor drink till they have
killed him and now are they ready
looking for a promise from thee so the
chief Captain then let the young man
depart and charged him see thou tell no
man that thou Hast showed these things
to
me um and then you said to 23 right read
that's the key version know it's 23 what
does the the Centurion ass sign read uh
and he called unto him two centurions
saying Make Ready 200 soldiers to go
to uh not sure for the exact it's all
right you're not going to visit anytime
soon but yeah so how many
soers um 200 soldiers okay to do
what and Horsemen three score and 10
meaning 60 okay oh okay okay 70 actually
three scores 60 and 10 70 that's King
James 70 so 200 soldiers and 70 Horsemen
right yes and uh Spearman uh 200 at the
third hour of the night okay so now Paul
appeals to over 200 guards with Spears
to protect them to kill these Jews if
they make an attempt on his
life yes why did he do that if you don't
have a right to protect yourself in your
life now go to Luke 22:
35-38 Luke 2235 38 if you guys wonder
what I'm doing it's my cat here he won't
leave or she won't leave I keep
forgetting it's a she she wants me to
pet her she's used to me petting her
Luke 2235 to 38 38 Luke 2235 38 read
slowly
okay see what he says here 35 through 38
yes what our Lord says okay and he said
unto them when I sent you without purse
and script and shoes lack ye anything
and they said
nothing then said he unto them but now
he that hath a purse let him take it and
likewise his script and he that hath no
sword let him sell His Garment
and buy one Now understand what Jesus is
saying when you're with me I took care
of you but now the time has come you
need to care for yourselves and provide
for yourselves and protect yourselves
why because read 37
why for I say unto you that is that this
that is written must ye be accomplished
in me and he was reckoned among the
transgressors before you finish it
scripture prophesied I'd be numbered
with the transgressors I'd be taken away
and killed with Sinners that means I
won't be with you physically to protect
you and provide for you so you need to
protect for yourselves provide for
yourselves and defend yourselves because
this has to have a fulfillment in me now
how do they respond notice their
response in 38 Luke 2238 notice their
response yeah they said uh and they said
Lord behold here are two swords and he
said unto them it is enough okay now if
you read the Greek it's not hey that's
enough for don't be stupid because
that's how some people would like to
explain it away no no that's sufficient
now the swords they're talking about
they're two types of swords you have
those long swords or you have a sword
that's like a dagger which was
multi-purpose Like a Knife where you can
cut food or you can stab this was what
you would
carry in your pouch as you're transing
from Village to Village to protect
yourselves against Highway Bandits so
he's saying look we have two he goes all
right that's enough you have all that
you need for now so number one why are
they carrying
swords number two why is he saying
that's all you need for now that's
sufficient for the
task oh um it's basically like the right
to to bear arms and so why didn't Jesus
say get rid of it if he's against the
right to bear arms and protect
yourself well um that's where like I
guess my heart objects um I don't care
about your heart I want you to do with
the text don't give me your heart give
me the
text why are they carrying swords and
then number two why is Jesus saying
that's sufficient you have all you need
for
now be well it would imply that he wants
them to use it in fact go to Matthew
2650 to
54 yeah your heart Proverbs 28:26 says
the fool trusts in his heart Jeremiah
17:9 says the heart is desperately
wicked and evil Beyond cure who can
understand it so keep trusting your
heart and I'm going to go with the
scriptures you see the point yes I yes I
see your point yeah don't let your heart
be your judge because your heart is
going to get a lot of people in trouble
and your heart may get a lot of people
killed because your heart says I don't
have a right to protect someone who's
helpless against someone stronger and
then the Lord's going to rebuke you for
that but anyway go to Matthew 26 Matthew
2650 to 54 oh 50 whoa okay okay and then
um and Jesus said unto him friend
wherefore art thou come when they came
and laid hands on Jesus and took him and
behold one of them which were with Jesus
stretched out his hand and Drew his
sword and struck a servant of the high
priest and smoked off his ear wait so
you're saying Jesus's disciples are
traveling with Jesus with a sword
ready yes I think it was reveal uh was
it Peter who ended up doing this yeah
but what no that's not my question my
question yeah it is Peter but so they
they're they're traveling with Jesus
with swords with
weapons yes oh wow so you mean they
never got the memo you should get rid of
all your swords because you're with me
and I'm against bearing
arms but now read what Jesus says though
oh wait on it gets better for you buddy
read what Jesus says then Jesus said
unto him put up again thy sword into his
placeit Jesus didn't say get rid of your
sword put it back in its sheath put it
back in its
place yeah why didn't he say get rid of
it in case of the time where where it's
needed but if if bearing arms is not
scriptural it's not our right why is
Jesus sounding like someone who would be
all for the NRA the right to bear arms
oh no uh I don't think I made the
distinction Sam I uh I understand the uh
the self-defense my issue is yeah
killing them um yeah who told you that
you can bear arms and defend yourself
and if that means killing them then
you're wrong where do you get that from
if self-defense means that the only way
I can protect the life of this person is
to take this guy's life because if I
don't then that person dies or I die
where did Jesus say you draw the line
you can defend yourself this far but
taking life no so when Paul asked Roman
soldiers to defend his life knowing that
there was a potential those Jews would
be killed for trying to murder
him you're more spiritual than Paul no
no I would I would never say anything
that's my point and then on top of that
besides Jesus saying put the sword back
in its place he didn't say get rid of it
we put that aside he who lives by the
sword dies by the sword which is true
because we don't make our livelihood or
spread the kingdom by the sword that's
not what I'm saying and you understand
that's not what I'm saying
didn't the apostles also
convert uh centurions Roman
soldiers yes they did like in Acts 10
Cornelius who was a
centurion yes and then in Acts 16 if you
read 30 to 34 the
Jailer they got converted to right yes
how come none of those converts were
told you can't be a soldier anymore you
have to now leave your vocation because
as Christians you don't have a right you
don't have a right to fight an army
where you're possibly going to kill
people okay I I I understand I see how
come they were not told to give up their
vocation and stop being soldiers and and
commanders of armies knowing that they'd
go out and have to kill
people he probably knew that it would be
needed in times of need okay so then if
we apply the logic that self-defense
means you can only defend yourself to a
certain extent but you can't take life
then that means no Christian should ever
become a
policeman
right yeah I suppose if
yeah you'd be desperately wrong if you
think that a Christian can't be a cop my
friend you're reading the wrong Bible
you have to come up with your own Bible
that's my point anyway I hope that made
sense though think about it don't go out
your heart your heart means nothing
because God is not
against just killing he's against
unjust murder there's a
difference killing someone justly means
that person has forfeited the right to
live and his life must be taken away and
this was mandated M mandated by God long
before Moses go to Genesis 9: 4
to6 Genesis 9:
4-6 and then now ask the Lord to make
your heart align itself with the word of
God not make the word of God agree with
your
heart okay uh so 4 to six uh but but
flesh with the life thereof which is in
which is the blood thereof shall ye not
eat and surely your blood of your lives
will I require I will require if anyone
takes your blood unjustly pay attention
anyone who takes your blood unjustly I
will require of that person whoever
sheds the blood of human unjustly I'll
require the life of that person from the
one who took it right yes can now keep
reading though at the hand of every
Beast will I require it at the hand of
man at the hand of Every Man's brother
will I require the life of man now
notice six keep
reading uh who so shth man's blood by
man shall his blood be shed okay now
this is a universal command before you
move on you got to read carefully
Universal command given to Noah After
the flood long before Moses he says this
is a command if a man murders someone by
a man he must be put to death read six
again who so shth man's blood by man
shall his blood be shed fin for in the
image of God made he man that's why when
a man murders someone unjustly he must
be put to death justly because that's a
consequence of murdering my image
Bearer okay so where do we find in the
Bible the condemnation of putting
someone to death who deserves to die for
murdering someone taking a life
unjust you got it yes so don't I don't
care about your heart don't care about
my heart care what the Bible says and
ask the Holy Spirit to sanctify your
heart to align itself with God's
thoughts not your emotions and you
acknowledge God above your thoughts he
will then guide you to the righteous
path means he'll bring you to what
scripture teaches so you can understand
and live it
out and that's what happened right now
you you acknowledging God God what
what's your will what do you say about
this and he's guiding you and now you
have to die to how you feel and think
God's thoughts after him